Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 133. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich befinde mich immer noch in der Ferne, sozusagen hier als Freibeuter der Information in fernen Ländern. Und als solcher wollte ich heute mal wieder ein kulturelles Thema auf den Plan rufen, was eine besondere Bedeutung gerade erlangt hat in ganz anderen Bereichen als das, womit es eigentlich was zu tun hat. Aber ich stürze mich auf das Original und kurz gesagt das Thema sind Piraten. Ihr wisst schon, Augenklappe, Kopftuch und all das, sprechende Papageien. Ich wollte mich mal der Wahrheit ein bisschen annähern und da hilft es ja immer, Leute zu haben, die sich auch ein bisschen mit dem Thema auskennen. Und auskennen tut sich damit der Roland, Roland Gratzer. Hallo. Ja, willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Schön, dass das geklappt hat. Und ja, steigen wir doch gleich mal ein.
Gerne.
Du wolltest auch immer Pirat werden.
Ich wollte als Kind immer Pirat werden.
Und bist irgendwie mit dem Messer zwischen den Zähnen, mit dem Spielplatz gelaufen.
Genau, genau. Das mit dem Astronaut. Da haben wir gedacht, das wird nichts, weil ich so schlecht Englisch kann. Dann habe ich ein bisschen auf Piraten umgesattelt und habe dann allerdings bemerkt, dass die moderne Schifffahrt meiner Vorstellung eines Piratenlebens nicht mehr so ganz entspricht.
Die moderne Schifffahrt.
Die moderne Schifffahrt, ja. Also keine Segel mehr und man kämpft auch nicht mehr mit Sehbeln und so weiter. Man kann sich heutzutage schwer auf einer Karibik Insel verstecken.
Ja, das ist schwierig. So mit Google Earth und so. Ich meine, was denkst du denn ist denn der Reiz? Warum wollen denn eigentlich alle Kinder Pirat sein?
Man muss keine Gesetze befolgen, außer die Gesetze des Schiffes, die uns in der Popkultur natürlich sehr nett vermittelt worden sind. Das heißt, alle halten zusammen, kämpfen gemeinsam, rauben Schätze, trinken rum.
Wir sitzen alle in einem Boot.
So ist es genau, trinken rum, auch wenn man vielleicht als Kind nicht wirklich eine Vorstellung hat, was rum eigentlich ist oder was der mit einem macht.
Aber es muss toll sein.
Es muss toll sein, wenn alle ihn wollen. Und ich glaube, einfach dieses Bild, das man da vermittelt kriegt, das will man einfach. Also diese Gesetzlosigkeit. Und ich war ein Kind, das auch sehr gern mit Waffen gespielt hat. Ich gebe das jetzt zu. Und deshalb habe ich auch immer gern mit Säbeln und so weiter gespielt und Sperre geworfen.
Aber es muss ja schon so diese Nahkampfwaffe sein, nicht schießen.
Maximal eine Kanone, also so eine richtige Kanone. Die Piraten allerdings gar nicht so oft eingesetzt haben.
Ja, da ist ja viel Legende. Wenn man sich das Piratenbild so anschaut, dann ist das ja eigentlich durch und durch popkulturell verklärt. So irgendwie halt diese Bilder, wie ich es auch schon angesprochen habe, mit, ich war mal, wissen wir ja alle hier, Pirates of the Caribbean, hat es dann auch nur noch mal auf weiteres verstärkt. Da ist halt immer so der coole, geschmeidige Oberpirat, ihm folgt die Posse Devote und Mit-Hingabe und wirft ihr eigenes Leben jederzeit gerne da dazwischen.
Das popkulturelle Bild ist gar nicht so weit weg, sagen wir mal so, allerdings dieser eine Captain, der jahrzehntelang sein Schiff leitet, das hat es nicht wirklich gegeben. Das popkulturelle Bild referenziert eben immer auf dieses goldene Zeitalter der Piraterie, das sogenannte zwischen 1690 und 1730 und da hat es sowohl Kapitäne gegeben, die am Schiff die absolute Autorität gehabt haben, also im Kampf die totale Autorität, allerdings sonst nicht. Und sie haben quasi vom Mannschaftsrat, wenn der Mannschaftsrat beschlossen hat, diesen Kapitän abzusetzen, dann ist der Kapitän abgesetzt worden. Das heißt, im Schnitt hat so ein Kapitän nie länger als drei, vier Jahre als Kapitän gedient, dann war er wieder normaler Pirat oder ist umbrucht worden von seiner Crew, weil er irgendwie falsche Entscheidungen getroffen hat.
Das heißt, er war auch gar nicht so richtig so eine Chef-Type, sondern eigentlich auch mehr so auf Zeit gewählt?
Genau, genau, genau. Nur im Kampf quasi. Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte. Da seine Autorität ausgelebt hat, hat er auch oft keine besonderen Anteile an der Beute und so weiter gehabt, sondern war ein einfaches Crew-Mitglied.
Das heißt, so ein Piratendasein ist durchaus basisdemokratisches Ereignis?
Genau, genau. Also, wenn man von dieser Zeit spricht, hat es da sehr viele Piratenorganisationen gegeben, die einen gewissen Prozentteil ihrer Beute in einen Art Fonds eingezahlt haben. Von diesem Fonds ist dann der Schiffsarzt bezahlt worden. Dann hat es klare Regelungen gegeben, wie viel Geld man bekommt, wenn man einen Finger verliert, eine Hand, einen Fuß, ein Auge und so weiter.
Tatsächlich.
Das ist bezahlt worden und der Rest ist quasi in so eine Veteranenkasse eingezahlt worden für die Verwundeten und so weiter, dass die, wenn sie auch nicht mehr kämpfen haben können, noch finanzielle Mittel zum Überleben gehabt haben.
Ach, also es ist ja eine richtige Sozialgesellschaft.
Genau, ja.
Na vielleicht sollten wir da erstmal nochmal auf den Hintergrund blicken. Piraterie ohne Schiffe ist sozusagen so nicht zu denken. Gab es denn Piraten schon seit es Schiffe gab oder ist das eigentlich erst ein Phänomen, was so eben später aufgekommen ist? Schiffe gibt es ja schon seit der Antike eigentlich.
Genau, und genauso lange gibt es auch schon Piraten. Stimmt, bei Asterix gibt es auch schon Piraten, die ziemlich dumm sind, aber auch eine sehr internationale Community, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Also der eine hat nur Lata eingesprochen.
Der Schwarzafrikaner.
Genau, mit diesem lächerlichen Akzent, den sie ihm gegeben haben.
Der ihm also Buchstaben auslässt und so.
Genau, genau, dummer Kapitän. Aber irgendwie haben sie auch einige Schiffe sicher abgenommen, sonst hätten sie das nicht 30 Hefte lang durchgehalten. Stimmt, immerhin. Allerdings war er gerade zur Zeit der Römer sehr schwer für Piraten, weil die Pompeius ist sehr genau, sehr stark gegen die Piraten vorgegangen, um diesen Mittelmeerwirtschaftsraum.
Pompeius. Das war ein römischer Stadthalter.
Genau, genau. Feind von Caesar und ist dann glaube ich von Caesar umgebracht worden, bin ich mir nicht mehr so ganz sicher, aber jedenfalls seit der Antike gibt es Piraterie in Griechenland, eine gewisse Zeit lang galten sie auch gar nicht als Verbrecher, sondern es war durchaus ein akzeptierter Weg, sein Geld zu verdienen. So eine verkauft, der andere raubt sie.
Ah, das war sozusagen Teil der Handelsordnung.
Bis sie darauf gekommen sind, dass dieser langsam international werdende Wahnverkehr sehr beeinträchtigt wird durch die Piraterie, dass sich die verschiedenen griechischen Städte zusammengeschlossen haben, um zumindest mal die Piraten zu bekämpfen.
Aber wer hat denn mit dem eigentlichen Schiffshandel angefangen? Waren das die Phönizier, also quasi die Palästinenser, oder waren es die Griechen selbst? Also, in Griechenland ist ja quasi die erste Städte, Hochkultur hat sich ja entwickelt mit einem für damalige Verhältnisse bemerkenswerten kulturellen Reichtum. Und da gab es dann auch die entsprechende Stabilität nämlich an, dass sich Handel quasi auch lohnt.
Genau, genau.
Und hier wurde dann aber im Wesentlichen im Mittelmeerraum...
Genau, genau. Und dass sich vor allem auch Schiffshandel lohnt.
Aber es waren jetzt nicht selber die Griechen, die jetzt losgezogen sind, oder?
Überhaupt jetzt als Seefahrer, oder wie meinst du?
Also wer ist sozusagen die eigentliche erste wirkliche Seefahrer-Nation gewesen?
Gute Frage. Gute Frage. Ich kann das jetzt wirklich nicht beantworten. Vielleicht waren es die für nichts hier.
Ja, die habe ich immer so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf, als die, die am meisten Handel treiben. Handelstreibende sind ja dann auch mal die, die sozusagen in der Ferne die Opportunity sehen, wenn man selber ein stabiles System hat. Und es geht einem gut, warum soll man so weit reisen, und dann kommen halt die anderen und wollen irgendwie daran teilhaben.
Genau, also es hat zu dieser Zeit auch politische Systeme gegeben, die quasi nur am Schiff existiert haben, die keine Landmasse gehabt haben, sondern einfach mal Städte überfallen haben, wenn sie was gebraucht haben oder Schiffe überfallen haben und quasi so im Schiffsbund durchs Mittelmeer gezogen sind.
Aber die Schiffe waren ja damals noch recht, naja, erste Generation halt, das dürfte ja nicht besonders schnell gewesen sein. Woraus hat sich dann so die Truppe rekrutiert? Waren das dann irgendwie alles Sklaven, wie man sich das immer so denkt?
Auf den Piratenschiffen eher nicht. Es hat natürlich sehr viele Piraten gegeben, die Sklaven gehalten haben oder Sklaven-Schiffe überfallen haben. Also da hat es keine Trennung gegeben. Die Piraten haben jetzt nicht gesagt, wir sind jetzt gute Menschen mit einem sozialpolitischen Gewissen. Wir überfallen keine Sklaven-Schiffe und verkaufen keine Sklaven. Das haben sie sehr wohlgetan. Allerdings haben sich auch sehr viele Sklaven dann dazu entschieden, selbst Pirat zu werden. Also das ist dann auf den Captain drauf angekommen, wie er das so gesehen hat.
Aber so ein internationales Handelsrecht in dem Sinne und so akzeptierte Codys, davon waren wir wahrscheinlich noch weit entfernt.
Da waren wir noch weit entfernt, ja.
Aber hat sich da irgendwann so eine Ordnung mal eingefangen? Ich meine, wenn die Piraten jetzt sozusagen, ach naja, entweder man verkauft es oder man wird geraubt, das wird ja auch nicht jedem gepasst haben.
Das hat nicht jedem gepasst, genau. Und die Griechen haben dann eben angefangen, Piraten wirklich einmal als Verbrecher zu bezeichnen. Das haben die Römer dann auch getan. Und seitdem galten Piraten einfach als stinknormale Verbrecher, sagen wir mal so. Allerdings je nachdem, wer gerade mit wem im Krieg war. Das heißt, wenn die andere Nation A mit Nation B im Krieg war, hat Nation A gesagt, kommt zu uns, Piraten, wir geben euch sogenannte Kapa-Briefe. Das heißt, wir tun euch nichts, solange ihr nur Schiffe der Nation B überfällt. Das hat sich eigentlich bis ins 18. Jahrhundert so gezogen.
Kapa-Briefe.
Kapa-Briefe, genau.
Das war sozusagen der Freibrief, wenn wir dann auf Hoer See von irgendeinem anderen Schiff der eigenen Flotte angetroffen wurden, haben die einfach gezeigt, wir dürfen offiziell böse sein.
Genau, allerdings haben dann viele Piraten gesagt, Gott, mein Gott, nehmen wir doch das Schiff an, ist ja wirklich egal. Also, vielen Piraten kommt man nicht drauf. Francis Drake ist ein sehr bekannter staatlicher Freibeuter, der sogar quasi in Friedenszeiten spanische Schiffe mit Erlaubnis von Elisabeth I überfallen hat, die er ausgeraubt hat. Stink normaler Pirat war, allerdings auch ein gefeierter Volksheld.
Ja, und dann auch gleich versenkt hat und das merkt ja dann sowieso keiner, wenn es überfallen hat.
So ist es, genau.
Ja, das ist das Schöne, auf Hoer See kann man ja recht spurlos Verbrechen begehen.
Ziemlich, also wenn da gerade irgendwo eine Insel ist, wo dann jemand landet und wieder abgeholt wird, was glaube ich sehr selten wirklich vorgekommen ist.
Also war das auch mal ein ganz furchtbares Gemetzel eigentlich?
Es war immer ein ziemlich furchtbares Gemetzel, allerdings Piraten haben nie Kriegsschiffe angegriffen, also selten Kriegsschiffe angegriffen, außer sie wurden eben von Stadt A dafür bezahlt, sondern Schiffe angegriffen, wo sie wissen, sie sind stärker. Und manche Piraten haben dann quasi mal eine Tepeche geschickt und gesagt, schaut's uns an, wir sind so stark. Also dieses ganze Geschrei und Waffen und Säbelrasseln, das hat es wirklich gegeben, quasi um zu zeigen, schaut's, wie stark wir sind, bevor ihr sterben wollt, gebt uns doch einfach alle eure Waren. Und wenn das dann nicht passiert ist, haben sie angegriffen und haben natürlich oft auch geschaut, dass das Schiff halbwegs heil bleibt vielleicht, vielleicht kann man das ja noch verkaufen.
Ja, stimmt das.
Und das Blödeste, was passieren kann, ist, wenn das Schiff untergeht, weil dann gibt's keine Waren mehr, die man da stellen kann.
Weil man die ja auch nicht so ohne Weiteres umladen kann, ne?
Genau, ja. Und also quasi ein untergegangenes Schiff hat für einen Piraten wenig Sinn, weil dann die ganze Fracht, die am Boden liegt, am Meeresgrund. Deshalb war der Kanonenbeschuss eigentlich sehr selten vorgekommen, weil damit die Gefahr sehr hoch war, dass man das Schiff versenkt.
Das heißt, so wie man das, da ist die Popkultur dann einfach ein bisschen überdreht?
Da ist die Popkultur dann ein bisschen überdreht. Also die gängigste Praxis war einfach, das Schiff zu ändern. Das heißt, Piraten-Schiffe waren meistens sehr schnelle Schiffe, meistens eher kleinere Schiffe, sind einfach hingefahren, raufgeklettert, haben gemetzelt und gemordet und haben sich dann der Wahn angeeignet.
Um die es ja eigentlich geht?
Genau.
Und Francis Drake hat das genauso gemacht oder ging es dir im Wesentlichen darum, die spanische Armada so Schiff für Schiff zu dezimieren?
Das lässt sich in so Kriegszeiten wunderbar kombinieren. Also man raubt das Schiff aus und kann es ja nachher noch immer versenken und kriegt dann auch noch Gold von der Königin. Win-win für die Engländer.
Aber der Begriff kommt nicht aus der Zeit.
Ich glaube nicht, aber er passt. Also zum Beispiel die gern genannte West India Trading Company, also diese holländische Handelsgesellschaft, hat sich um 1620 gegründet und war im Ursprung keine Handelsgesellschaft, sondern eigentlich eine Art Pirateriegesellschaft. Die gesagt haben, wir wollen Schiffe überfallen und es ist auch in der Gründungsurkunde der West India Trading Company steht drinnen, wir wollen alles tun, um zu verhindern, dass es Frieden gibt. Weil wenn es Frieden gibt, gibt es keine Kappa-Briefe mehr und dann ist das blöd.
Noch nicht so ganz. Also die West India Trading Company ist gegründet worden von den Holländern.
Genau.
Die ja eigentlich das führende Schifffahrts-Volk waren eigentlich zu der Zeit, oder?
Genau, neben den Engländern.
Neben den Engländern.
Und haben sie quasi als Piratengesellschaft gegründet. Wirklich als Gesellschaft. Also es hat durchaus Investoren gegeben, Geschäftsmänner und Adelige, die in diese Piratengesellschaften auch investiert haben.
West India bezieht sich aber auf?
Auf die Karibik.
Amerika.
Genau, genau.
Was man damals aber noch als Westindische Inseln bezeichnet hätte, ja.
Und also quasi bevor es eine Handelsgesellschaft wurde, die dann auch sehr erfolgreich gegen die Piraten gekämpft hat, war es eigentlich selbst eine Piratengesellschaft, die sich eben in ihrer Gründungsurkunde gewünscht haben, dass es keinen Frieden gibt. Weil Frieden bedeutet keine Kappa-Briefe mehr, damit mehr Stress.
Das heißt, man kann, ach so, mehr Stress, weil man dann nicht ohne Worte was austrauben kann.
Genau, weil man dann keinen Schutz von einer Nation hat und so weiter.
Das heißt, die Holländer haben sich dann, also Kappa-Briefe von wem haben sie sich denn ausstellen lassen? Von Engländern? Je nachdem, okay, wir waren ja, also wir sind jetzt sozusagen von der Antike ein bisschen fix bis 1600 vorgeprägt.
Ja, das stimmt, das war fast ein bisschen schnell.
Ja, ja, also ich frage mich, was ist denn da passiert in der Zwischenzeit? Ich meine, das ist ja ohnehin eigentlich das dunkle Zeitalter, in dem man irgendwie immer so das Gefühl hat, da war so Rom, also erst so die Griechen, dann kam irgendwie Rom und dann passiert irgendwie erstmal nichts.
Und dann Kolumbus. Es gibt ja sogar Historiker, die meinen, dass das Mittelalter gar nicht existiert hat, sondern eine Erfindung war. Ja, ja, das sind glaube ich ein bisschen komische Historiker. Aber die meinen, dass das einfach eine Urkundenfälschung ist, dass wir quasi jetzt im Jahr 1.600 leben.
Ah, dass da einfach ein paar hundert Jahre dazu erfunden wurden, die es gar nicht gab?
Genau, ja.
Aber...
Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, vor allem, wenn jetzt solche römischen Sachen gefunden werden, lassen sich doch mittlerweile so mit modernen Technologien das Alter relativ genau bestimmen. Das würde ja dann auffliegen, oder?
Deshalb müssen wir das nicht lernen in der Schule, diese Historiker, dankenswerterweise. Aber im Mittelalter hat es natürlich genauso Piraterie gegeben.
Aber gab es also vor allem, wer war so die dominierende, die Schifffahrt? Ich meine, gut, die Römer sind so ein bisschen an sich selbst zerbrochen.
Genau, genau.
Was die gemacht haben, ist mir dann allerdings auch unklar in den Jahrhundertjahren.
Die Italiener jetzt, oder?
Jaja, also dann waren es dann die Italiener.
Ja, wenig.
Ja, erst hatten sie Hochkultur und danach hingen sie nur noch am Strand.
Genau, und dann sind sie ja quasi entweder von deutschen Kaisern besetzt worden oder vom Vatikanstaat. Ist auch nicht leicht. Na gut, sie haben das Finanzsystem relativ hoch entwickelt, also das Bankensystem.
Gut, also es hat sich eigentlich alles sehr viel mehr inländisch entwickelt.
Ja, natürlich. Seepharz, weil wir schon bei Italien waren, war natürlich Venedig eine sehr wichtige Seemacht, bereits im Mittelalter.
Ja, aber vor Kolumbus spielte sich quasi alles innerhalb von Europa ab.
Genau, oder zumindest am Atlantik entlang und runter nach Afrika.
Und nach Indien.
Und nach Indien, genau, was ein sehr weiter Weg war.
Und gab es dann auch so quasi auf der Strecke, ich meine, das ist ja auch heute noch eine selbe wie die Piratenstrecke, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass da auch eine Menge abging.
Ja, vor allem an der Westküste Afrikas hat es sehr viele Piraten gegeben, die ganze Zeit über quasi. Vor allem wie dann dieser Afrika-Handel, das jetzt einmal mit diesem euphemistischen Wort zu beschreiben, also diese Ausbeutung des afrikanischen Kontinents begonnen hat mit Elfenbein und dem wahnsinnigen Sklavenhandel, hat es natürlich dort sehr viele Piraten gegeben. Und natürlich auch in der Ost- und in der Nordsee, das heißt rund um die Hansestädte, die ja schon früh begonnen haben, mit Schifffahrt zu handeln, untereinander zu handeln, haben sich eine sehr starke Pirateriebewegung auch entwickelt, die sich da auf diesen ganzen kleinen Inseln sehr gut verstecken hat können. Bis quasi auch die Hansestädte beschlossen haben, damit ein Ende zu machen und berühmt ein Pirat, glaube ich im 17. Jahrhundert gestorben, Klaus Störtebeker, in Hamburg geköpft mit dieser irgendwie sehr schönen Legende, dass sie ihm den Kopf abgehackt haben. Bevor hat er noch gesagt, hackt mir den Kopf ab und ich werde dann meine Mannschaft abmarschieren, also an meiner Mannschaft vorbeilaufen und so viele ich schaffe, so viele lasst er frei. Dann wurde ihm der Kopf abgehackt und er ist bei der gesamten Besatzung vorbeimarschiert, ohne Kopf, und die wurden dann freigelassen.
Das ist so schön.
Das ist wirklich schön.
Das muss wahr sein.
Das muss wahr sein, ja stimmt. Also Piraten haben auch immer wieder das Zeug zu Volkshelden gehabt, natürlich, weil sie ja quasi...
Was hat denn der Störtebeker gemacht?
Der hat einfach Hanse-Schiffe überfallen.
Und der saß ja aber quasi direkt vor Hamburg, oder?
Ja, also so in diesem Nordsee-Raum.
Nordsee-Raum.
Nord-Nord-Ostsee-Raum. Rund um Helgoland haben sich die meisten Piraten versteckt. Und da hat es bereits um 1400 eine sehr große Piratenbewegung gegeben. Ich habe es mir extra aufgeschrieben, weil ich den Namen nicht mehr vergesse. Die Ligetela. Ligetela heißt übersetzt die Gleichteiler. Und das ist auch ein sehr schöner Name. Und genau darum ist es gegangen, wie wir auf allen Schiffen teilen, das Ganze unter uns zu gleichen Teilen auf.
Wie lief denn das logistisch ab? Ich meine, man stellt sich immer so die Piraten vor, die sind halt auf ihrem Schiff. Aber ich meine, die wohnen da ja nicht die ganze Zeit. Man will ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit nur auf so einem Schiff sein.
Eben nicht. Also dann gibt es quasi meistens eben Verstecke. Oder in der Karibik eine ganze Pirateninsel, die in der starken Zeit sehr gut besetzt waren. Also Tartuga, der Klassiker. Jamaika, auch sehr viele Piratenstützpunkte. Dort hat man die Beute dann hingebracht und ich mache wieder einen kleinen Sprung nach vorne ins 18. Jahrhundert. Da war auf Jamaika der Geldumlauf bisweilen größer als in London. Also das Geld, das die Piraten auf die Insel gebracht haben, dort getauscht haben, dort irgendwas gekauft haben. Es war ein riesiges Piratenbinnenwirtschaftssystem mit unfassbaren Geldmengen eigentlich. Und wenn man jetzt glaubt, dass jeder Captain seinen Schatz auf irgendeiner Insel vergraben hat, das war wahrscheinlich nichts. Also es gibt nur William Kidd, wo es wirklich verbrieft ist, dass er seinen Schatz irgendwo vergraben hat. Also meistens wären die Schätze ehrlich gesagt zu groß gewesen, um ein riesiges Loch zu graben und das wieder zuzuschieben.
Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei Störtebeker, weil er einfach auch nicht der einzige wirklich bekannte Pirat ist. Ich meine, er war sicherlich nicht der einzige, oder?
Nein, aber er ist halt der berühmteste, sagen wir mal so.
Und wie muss man sich das vorstellen, dass er so hat mühelos treiben lassen können? Ich meine, wenn so viel Handel war zwischen den einzelnen Hansestädten, dann muss es ja eigentlich auch ein extrem großes Interesse gegeben haben, dem militärisch beizukommen.
Ja, ja. Das wurde dann natürlich auch immer wieder versucht. Aber diese Piraten haben natürlich auch in der Bevölkerung eine starke Unterstützung gehabt.
Weil?
Weil sie natürlich eine Art Volkshelden waren, weil sie gegen die Obrigkeit gekämpft haben. Also ich kann mir das, ich war ja nicht dabei damals in der Hanse, aber ich kann mir das natürlich schon so vorstellen, dass man quasi in Hamburg am Hafen arbeitet, in irgendwelchen Elendsvierteln, wo man sieht, wie quasi das Bürgertum reicher und reicher wird. Man selbst hat nichts von dem Reichtum, also ist das natürlich eine große Freude, wenn da jemand kommt und denen den Reichtum wegnimmt.
Beziehungsweise, die gelingen hat sich dem sogar anzuschließen, weil man dort eben einfach die Gleichteiler. Die Gleichteiler. Das heißt, im Prinzip ist das Piratentum eigentlich auch so eine soziale Befreiungsbewegung?
Man kann es durchaus als soziale Befreiungsbewegung sehen. Ja, also Englern im 17. Jahrhundert, oder 16. Jahrhundert, kann man sich vorstellen, ein klassisches Volltalsystem natürlich. Die Bauern haben die Wälder und die Wiesen und so weiter bewirtschaften können, wie sie wollen. Also, damit sie eben jetzt was zum Essen haben und so weiter. Und dann im 17. Jahrhundert die Bewegung der Einzäunung begonnen, wo die Adeligen gesagt haben, das ist meine Wiesen, wie man gut österreichisch sagen würde, ich bau jetzt einen Zaun herum. Ich mach jetzt zwar nichts mit dem Land, gehe da vielleicht jagen, weil das ja mein Wald ist und so weiter.
Das ist die Vernichtung der Almende.
Genau, die Vernichtung der Almende. Und das heißt, da sind innerhalb von wenigen Jahren plötzlich zigtausende Menschen ohne Nahrungsgrundlage dargestanden. Sie konnten nicht mehr jagen gehen, sie konnten nichts mehr anbauen, weil einfach das alles eingezäunt war. Und quasi dieses dadurch entstandene Landproletariat musste irgendwas machen. Und viele sind dann natürlich in die sogenannte neue Welt gesägt, weil sie gehofft haben, da gibt es einfach was Neues. Oder da kann ich mich quasi aus dieser feudalen Herrschaft befreien. Nur war es dort natürlich nicht anders. Also die englischen Siedlerstädte, da war es ja nicht leicht leben. Also die erste Siedlerstadt Jamestown, glaube ich, hat die Geheißenwehr fast zugrunde gegangen, wenn auch ein Mythos, der allerdings auch stimmt, wenn die Indianer rund um Pocahontas da nicht geholfen hätten. Allerdings, was nicht erzählt wird, ist, dass ein Großteil oder ein sehr großer Teil der damaligen Siedler auf gewisse Art und Weise zu den Ureinwohnern übergelaufen ist und gesagt haben…
Welches Jamestown meinst du jetzt? Also wo…
Die erste Siedlerstadt, die erste britische Siedlerstadt in Nordamerika. Also überhaupt haben sich sehr viele immer wieder abgesetzt und haben gesagt, warum…
Im heutigen Virginia.
Genau, genau. Warum soll ich quasi einem englischen Herrn dienen, wenn ich da mit den Ureinwohnern gut leben kann? Das ist eine Geschichte, die sehr selten erzählt wird oder eine Geschichte, die man eigentlich nicht lernt. Aber es haben sich sehr, sehr viele abgesetzt in der ganzen neuen Welt. Also es gibt eine Geschichte…
Also die ersten Hippies sozusagen.
Genau, genau. Von einem Schiff, das gekentert ist und dann auf den Bermudas gelandet ist und die militärischen Chefs des Schiffes haben natürlich gesagt, ja und du machst das und du machst das und so weiter. Und die sind dann draufgekommen, wozu, also wozu sollen wir ein Schiff bauen, nach Virginia fahren, dort auf einer Plantage arbeiten, wenn wir hier auf dem Bermudas leben können?
Wo einfach die Füße an den Bäumen hängen und überhaupt?
So ist es, so ist es. Und das hat sich zu einer veritalen Mäuterei gemausert, bis die Redelsführer erschossen waren. Punktum. Die Redelsführer waren erschossen und man ist weiter nach Virginia. Also quasi das zusammenzufassen, die Almende war weg, man braucht was Neues und hat dann quasi überhaupt diese Chance gesehen, irgendwie eine andere Alternative zu leben. Und das war auf den Piratenschiffen, es waren sehr internationale Communities, sagen wir mal so, es hat da keine Standesunterschiede gegeben, es hat keine Unterschiede zwischen den verschiedenen Rassen gegeben und so weiter, das war dort einfach kein Thema. Und im Vergleich dazu, wenn man sich entscheiden muss, ob man jetzt auf einem offiziellen Schiff der britischen Marine dient, wo man oft jahrelang um seinen Salt betrogen worden ist, einfach nicht gezahlt, weil sie quasi die Saltstellen gedacht haben, der stirbt sowieso irgendwann. Im Vergleich zu einem Piratenschiff, wo ich eine Pensionskasse habe, also da dürfte die Entscheidung nicht allzu schwer fallen. Und jetzt ganz zynisch gesagt, gestorben ist man sowieso.
Ja, das ist ein interessanter Aspekt, den ich so noch nie gesehen habe, dass eigentlich, dass einerseits eben so eine Loslösung von einer ungerechten Gesellschaft ist, wo eben der Kapitalismus Wildwuch hat und wo eben wenige das Meiste haben und die allermeisten eben das wenigste. Da gibt es ja genug Parallelen zu heute im Prinzip. Und dass die dann einfach sagen, okay, warum soll ich mich eurem Sicherheitssystem anschließen, wenn ich auch ein anderes Sicherheitssystem haben kann. Der Unterschied zu heute ist natürlich offensichtlich. Heute gibt es keine staatenlosen Gebiete mehr im eigentlichen Sinne, also wenigen unbedeutenden Ausnahmen. Und im Falle von Störtebecker muss man nur bis Helgoland fahren und dann war man sozusagen schon außerhalb des Zugriffs der Autoritäten.
Was damals sehr, sehr weit war natürlich im Vergleich zu heute.
Stimmt. Richtig weit.
Richtig weit wahrscheinlich, ja.
Die Karibik.
Ja, die ist natürlich noch eine Ecke weiter. Ach so, die Karibik Deutschlands, ja.
So, und war denn das wirklich immer so, dass jetzt, also ich meine, das klingt jetzt so mit, ja, die Piraten und die waren dann immer unter sich immer gleich, ich meine, ist das immer wirklich so gewesen oder gab es da nicht dann auch irgendwann entsprechende Regime? Ich meine, wenn man erst mal Macht hat, dann tendiert man dazu, sie zu missbrauchen oder ist das Piraten-Modell an sich so selbst unterstützend gewesen, dass das nicht passiert ist?
Ich fühle natürlich auch immer diese schönen Sachen und will natürlich auch immer diese schönen Sachen erzählen, weil die so schön sind.
Und wegen deines Kindheitstraums.
Und wegen meines Kindheitstraums, wer weiß. Vielleicht. Natürlich nicht. Also es hat natürlich, Piraten haben sich natürlich auch untereinander bekämpft. Was dann vielleicht eine gewisse Art regulativ war. Also wenn ein Kapitän zu mächtig geworden ist und nicht einfach von anderen Kapitänen überfallen worden. Und damit hat sich das auch wieder ausgeglichen. Und wie wir bereits vorher gesagt haben, Piraten haben ja genauso auch mit Sklaven gehandelt, wenn es ihnen gerade gepasst hat. Also es ist ihnen natürlich letztlich auch um den Profit gegangen. Allerdings mit dem Unterschied, dass auch der Schiffsjunge von diesem Profit profitiert hat.
Dieses soziale System mit Pensionskassen und so weiter, was du beschrieben hast. Ab wann war das auch schon von Anfang an so?
Das war nicht von Anfang an so. Das war quasi im karibischen Zeitalter. Genau, genau so ums Anfang des 18. Jahrhunderts herum.
Okay, also da kam Columbus, ist irgendwie los, wollte nach Indien, meint es auch gefunden zu haben, war aber in Kuba und so weiter, ist dann noch bis Nordamerika gekommen und dachte auch immer noch, das wäre Indien, war es aber nicht, dann ist er irgendwann auch gestorben und wusste es nicht oder vielleicht hat er auch eine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. So, und das führt dann natürlich zu dieser zunehmenden Kolonialisierung und mit diesem, ich meine, wen hat es denn da schon hingebracht? Das war ja eigentlich auch alles immer schon so die Leute, die gesagt haben, ich habe jetzt hier entweder keine Perspektive oder zumindest glaube ich da drüben mehr Perspektive zu haben. Genau, oder die, die......wunderstrom gehabt.
Oder die, die die hin haben müssen, weil das Konzept des Gefängnisses hat es ja früher nicht so gegeben, also dass man die ganzen Verbrecher quasi in irgendein Gefängnis sperrt, deshalb hat man sie irgendwo anders hingebracht, wo sie arbeiten sollen.
So wie Australien auch.
So wie Australien auch, genau, und so weiter. Also jetzt England, das ja quasi dann in dieser Zeit die führende Seemacht war, später dann eben die haben zigtausende Iren, Katholiken, in die neue Welt geschickt und wo sie dann quasi gemeinsam mit afrikanischen Sklaven auf den Plantagen arbeiten mussten. Und jetzt zurück zu Kolumbus. Nach Kolumbus waren natürlich die Spanier sehr mächtig im Atlantik und haben einmal damit begonnen, Südamerika auszumerzen, also quasi jede einzelne Unze Silber zu finden und nach Spanien zu transportieren. Und eben diese Silbertransporte haben die Piraterie ungemein beflügelt, also die Piraterie rund um Europa, einmal rundherum, gefördert von den Engländern, auch die Franzosen, die sich dachten, ich schätze mal ein, sie haben sich das so gedacht, warum sollen wir nach Südamerika fahren, wenn die Spanier uns eh das Silber bringen und wir holen es uns einfach vor Biarritz ab.
Und zwar von den Piraten, die wir mit Kappa-Briefen ausstatten, die da sozusagen auch eine Protektion hatten, aber offiziell waren sie es dann selber gar nicht, die Profiteure.
Genau. Also haben sie es dann aber auch immer die Kohle befreit, die Piraten, die so spanische Silberschiffe verfallen haben, haben eigentlich einen Großteil der Beute bekommen. Circa 10 bis 20 Prozent musste dann an den König abgeliefert werden. Und ich traue ihnen jetzt mal zu, dass sie auch ziemlich beschissen haben bei der Abrechnung. Bestimmt. Und ja, dann sind eben...
Dürfte den Spaniern aber auch nicht gerade gepasst haben.
Dürfte den Spaniern überhaupt nicht gepasst haben.
Was haben die dagegen getan?
Ja, sie haben versucht, Kriegsschiffe mitzuschicken und so weiter. Aber so einen Silbertransporter kann man sich ziemlich gut vorstellen, dass das ein total behäbiges Gerät ist, wenn das Silber transportieren muss. Und dann so ein kleines Piratenschiff, das da her segelt und das ausraubt.
Eine kleine Nussschale.
Genau, genau. Und die oft auch quasi von hinten kommt, ganz fies. Und die man mit Kanonen nicht wirklich treffen kann, weil man mit den Kanonen ja bekanntlich nur seitlich schießen hat können. Das heißt, eben, und Piraten haben sich einer solchen Seeschlag so gut wie nie, also selten gestellt.
Gab es denn keine Schiffe, die Kanonen nach hinten hatten?
Es gab solche Schiffe, die hat es schon sehr früh sogar gegeben, nach vorn und nach hinten, aber das war dann halt meistens nur eine. Und bis die wieder neu geladen ist, war das Piratenschiff eigentlich schon da.
Verstehe.
Die Piraten haben allerdings Kanonenkugeln gehabt, die keine Explosion hervorgerufen haben, sondern zwei Kanonenkugeln mit einer Kette miteinander verbunden, wo sie dann quasi auf den Masten geschossen haben, der dann eingekracht ist. Damit manövriere und fake.
Ohne, dass es untergeht?
Ohne, dass es untergeht. Und wenn geht die gesamte Besatzung unterm Segel liegt?
Pfiffig?
Sehr pfiffig. Blöd waren sie nie, ne?
Aber trotzdem, ich meine, um so ein Schiff zu bauen, bedarf es natürlich schon einer gewissen Logistischen und Ingenieurs-Leistung.
Oder man stiehlt es.
Ah, okay, aber sind denn alle Schiffe, die man so stehlen kann, dann auch mal gleich piratentauglich?
Natürlich nicht alle, ne? Das stimmt natürlich. Da ist dann quasi von Vorteil, wenn man vielleicht einen Hafen überfallen hat.
Aber wurden überall Schiffe gebaut? Ich meine, war jetzt so der Schiffsbau in jedem Hafen?
Nein, nein, nein. Also der war hauptsächlich eben in Europa selbst. Und die sind dann in die neue Welt gefahren. Und die lagen dort vor Anker, weil die so einen Piraten eben auch sehr früh ausgenutzt sind oder sehr früh draufgekommen sind, dass man einen Hafen sehr gut überfallen kann, indem man nicht vom See aus angreift, weil das war natürlich eine riesige Festung mit Kanonen, sondern indem man hinten auf der Insel landet und von hinten die Festung einnimmt.
Und dann haben sie sich der Schiffe bemächtigt?
Dann haben sie sich einfach der Schiffe bemächtigt, ja. Sehr pffig.
So, also dieses goldene Zeitalter wurde also im Wesentlichen dadurch ausgelöst, dass der Handel mit der neuen Welt vor allem stattgefunden hat. Das war eigentlich so der Auslöser. Und natürlich, dass man mit der Karibik, aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur mit der Karibik, diese Vielzahl an Inseln hatte. Also im Prinzip eine wunderbare Vorlage für ein Hideout, wo man einfach machen konnte, was man wollte.
Weil die Karibik damals natürlich sehr attragreich war, also was Tabak betrifft, was Zucker betrifft. Wir raten einem nicht immer nur Gold geraubt.
So viel hat es dann auch wieder nicht gegeben.
Alles, was irgendwie zu veräußern war.
Und auch für den Konsum.
Genau, genau, genau. Ist durchaus praktisch.
Der Rum.
Und der Tabak.
Der Tabak. Der Rausch.
Und gerade deshalb, weil man quasi zum x-ten Mal dieses goldene Zeitalter erwähnt, irgendwann sind die führenden Seemächte auch draufgekommen. Es bringt eigentlich nichts, wenn wir, also es bringt natürlich total viel, wenn wir dauernd Krieg miteinander führen, aber uns dann quasi mit Kappa-Briefen und so weiter. Wir sollten eigentlich gemeinsam gegen die Piraterie vorgehen.
Das heißt, wir wurden dann irgendwann als generelles Problem angesehen, weil die einfach so stark geworden sind.
Also das Piraten wurden als generelles Problem angesehen. Ein, unter Anführungszeichen, wichtiger Schritt dann für die Anti-Piraterie-Justiz war, dass man die Piraten auch in der Karibik hängen hat dürfen. Früher hat das noch in England oder in den Ländern passieren dürfen.
Achso, man muss sie dann erstmal wieder zurückführen sozusagen.
Genau, und ein Pirat am Schiff ist nie gut, schätze ich mal. Gerade für die Moral der Truppe sehr schlecht. Und war auch früher so, dass man quasi den Kapitän geköpft hat, die Mannschaft freigelassen hat. Irgendwann ist man dazu übergegangen, die gesamte Mannschaft aufzuhängen.
Einfach, um ein Exempel zu setzen.
Einfach, um ein Exempel zu statuieren. Genau.
Hat aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktioniert oder?
Hat nicht so gut funktioniert, aber irgendwann ist die Piraterie in diesen Gegenden einfach sehr stark zurückgegangen.
Schon in Folge dieser Bekämpfung. Das heißt, das Bedarf bedurfte sozusagen dieser Allianz an der Stelle.
Genau, genau.
Vielleicht nochmal zu diesem, wir sprechen zwar viel, aber das muss man jetzt nochmal bringen, was du eingangs schon erklärt hast. Dieses Sozialsystem, dieses System dergleichen, also das zeichnet ja im Prinzip auch ein deutliches Bild des Miteinanders und des Alltags, des Piraten-Alltags. Man hat ja auch immer nur Männer, zum Beispiel, im Blick. Gab es da auch Frauen irgendwie, hatten die Familien, hatten die im Prinzip, war ihr Hideout auch eine richtige Siedlung oder sind das eigentlich immer nur so, ist das immer so ein Ferienurlaub gewesen, ich bin jetzt mal zwei, drei Jahre Pirat und dann fahre ich wieder nach Hause?
Sind zwar einige auch wieder nach Hause gefahren, aber viele sind geblieben, weil es nicht so leicht war, als Pirate wieder zurückzukehren.
Aber ich meine, so ohne Frauen funktioniert das ja dann wahrscheinlich auch nur sehr begrenzt?
Funktioniert auch nur sehr begrenzt, das stimmt. Also es hat natürlich durchaus auch Frauen in diesen Piraten-Häfen gegeben. Wie soll man sagen, es hat natürlich auch weibliche Piraten gegeben, es hat Hausfrauen gegeben, es hat Kellnerinnen gegeben, es hat...
Eine komplett eigene Infrastruktur.
Eine komplett eigene Infrastruktur, genau, so kann man sagen.
Im Prinzip waren das auch Siedler, die sich eigentlich nur von den etablierten Bürgerrechtsformen und Statensystemen unabhängig gemacht haben.
Genau, da quasi überhaupt einmal Bürgerrecht etabliert haben im Vergleich zu den anderen Staaten.
Beziehungsweise überhaupt einmal Bürgerrecht gemacht haben.
Es hat auch in so manchen Piraten-Gemeinschaften, wenn wir vorher darüber geredet haben, dass das ja fast nur Männer waren, also eine Art, wie soll man sagen, es war eine Art Ehe zwischen zwei Männern gegeben. Also das heißt jetzt nicht, dass die verheiratet waren und miteinander Kinder großgezogen haben, sondern dass man so eine Art Zweckgemeinschaft eingegangen ist, zusammen einen Haushalt geführt hat und während der eine auf Beute zugehe, ist der andere zu Hause geblieben, damit nicht beide sterben. Und falls der andere verwundet zurückkommt, dass der, der zurückgeblieben ist, wieder auf Beutefahrt fahren kann und gewinnt nach Hause bringt und so weiter.
Aber das hat jetzt mit Homosexualität nichts zu tun, das waren einfach Zweckgemeinschaften.
Nein, nein, das waren Zweckgemeinschaften. Genau, ja.
Ah, und jeder Pirat hatte sozusagen dann noch so ein Haus-Pirat und man wechselte immer die Räume?
Natürlich nicht jeder, aber es hat in manchen Gemeinschaften so als Konzept der Altersvorsorge gegeben, ja.
Das heißt, innerhalb eines Systems der gleichen und der gegenseitigen Unterstützung und Alterssicherung gab es dann auch noch mal auf individueller Ebene sozusagen noch mal dieses System? Genau, aber wie weit ging das, gab es dann auch gleich noch eine Rechtsordnung, Gerichte?
Es hat Gerichte nicht in dem Sinn, wie wir sie kennen, gegeben, aber es hat natürlich gewisse Art von, wie soll man sagen, juristischen Schriften gegeben, die hauptsächlich das Leben auf dem Schiff festgelegt haben. Und deshalb kann man das oft auch nicht wirklich mit einer Demokratie vergleichen, weil da steht zwar drinnen, dass jeder Pirat, es gibt so eine Schiffsordnung, die da überliefert ist oder die quasi übrig ist, die es noch gibt, dass jeder Pirat so viel rumtrinken kann, wie er will. Wenn er allerdings nach acht Uhr eine Kerze anzündet, dann ist er mit dem Tod zu bestrafen. Ja, Verdunkelungsgebot.
Ach so.
Quasi.
Verstehe.
Also natürlich unfassbar drakonische Strafen für totale Kleinigkeiten.
Aber da stand ja die Sicherheit aller auf dem Spiel.
Da stand die Sicherheit aller auf dem Spiel, das stimmt. Oder zum Beispiel unten. Ich glaube, es gibt auch eine Regel, wer unter Deck betrunken ist. Oben, das ist kein Problem, aber wer unten betrunken ist, wird auch mit dem Tod bestraft. Ach. Weil? Keine Ahnung. Ehrlich gesagt. Vielleicht, dass er unabsichtlich irgendetwas anzündet oder so. Wahrscheinlich auch wieder Sicherheitsgedanke und Schießpulver und was weiß ich.
Genau, da will man keine Loonies rumstreuen haben, die dann irgendwie schabarnackt machen.
Genau, genau.
Aber das galt halt nur fürs Schiff.
Das galt nur fürs Schiff, ja.
Und in den Piratenhäfen, gibt's da irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, wie da die Ordnung lief, angesehen von diesen individuellen Lebensgemeinschaften?
Zugegebenermaßen, man weiß natürlich extrem wenig über diese Piratengemeinschaften, weil entweder das sind die Berichte von staatlicher Seite, die dann natürlich von wahnsinnigen anarchistischen, bösen, vielköpfigen Hydras berichten, also dem absolut Bösen, andererseits natürlich die total romantischen Berichte von Piraten selber oder Leute, die dann über Piraten geschrieben haben, dass das alles Edelmänner waren und so weiter, was natürlich auch nicht stimmen kann. Also man weiß letztlich sehr wenig darüber, aber es hat durchaus –meine Interpretation des Ganzen –dass es durchaus eine Art Gerichtsbarkeit gegeben hat, weil es hat einfach auch sehr lange funktioniert, also es hat, glaube ich, hat dann keine Materie reingegeben, sondern der Kapitän ist einfach abgesetzt worden. Jetzt am Schiff und dann quasi das auch auf Land, also es hat natürlich ein sehr demokratisches Verständnis des Miteinanders gegeben und Räte, wo quasi beschlossen worden ist, wen greifen wir an, mit wem arbeiten wir zusammen, wen mögen wir nimmer, wo ist da rum, quasi. Also rum wurde wirklich sehr viel getrunken, das ist kein Gerücht.
Wir wollten das Zeitalter 1690 bis 1730, das sind 40 Jahre, das ist ja nicht viel.
Das ist nicht viel, aber es hat gereicht, um ein riesiges popkulturelles Phänomen auszutreten eigentlich.
Das heißt, warum 1690? Also gibt es einen besonderen Anlass, woran man das jetzt festmacht? Gab es irgendeine entscheidende Schlacht oder irgendein Aufkommen von einer bestimmten Person, die das jetzt markiert? Warum nicht 1689?
Vielleicht, weil es eine runde Zahl ist.
Aber warum nicht 20, 30 Jahre früher?
Es fällt einfach in die Zeit, wo dieser Atlantikhandel begonnen hat, richtig groß zu werden. Das heißt, wo nicht mehr nur Abenteuer und spanische Goldräuber und Silberräuber unterwegs waren, sondern wo Kolonien begonnen haben, wo Plantagen jetzt wirklich groß geworden sind und wirklich große Mengen an Baumwolle, Tabak und Zucker nach Europa zurückgebracht haben. Das heißt, es war ein großes Potenzial da, sich dieser Dinge zu bemächtigen. Gleichzeitig die Nationen, Spanien, Frankreich, England, dauernd auch im Klinch miteinander und gegeneinander. Das heißt, wie bereits erwähnt, viele Kaperbriefe zum haben und so weiter. Also quasi mit der Explosion des Wirtschaftsraumes Atlantik ist quasi auch die Explosion der Piraterie gekommen. Das heißt, es hat sich so gegenseitig bedingt.
Und gab es da…
Nein, es hat sich nicht gegenseitig bedingt, das ist ein blöder Satz, Entschuldigung.
Es hat sich auf jeden Fall gegenseitig befruchtet.
Es hat sich gegenseitig befruchtet, genau.
So habe ich das auch verstanden. Und gab es jetzt dann sozusagen vom Start weg auch schon so bekannte Piraten, also so… Meine, vorhin hast du noch gesagt, selten das mal ein Pirat sich lange gehalten hat. Nach drei Jahren war der weg. Ich meine, das ist jetzt kein Zeitraum, wo er sagen würde, da wird man irgendwie schnell berühmt. Aber trotzdem, was ja auch schon so ein paar Namen fallen lassen, gibt es ja durchaus auch Namen, die so ein bisschen in der Ewigkeit festgeschrieben sind. Wer war denn so der erste wirkliche, bekannte Pirat dieses goldenen Zeitalters, an dem man vielleicht diese Goldenhaftigkeit dieses Zeitalters auch festmachen kann?
Also es gibt quasi die großen, also Henry Morgan. Der mit dem Rum, genau. William Kitt, den wir bereits erwähnt haben. Und Blackbeard, den hat er gar nicht, genau, den Blackbeard. Das sind so quasi große Namen, über die man ehrlich gesagt dann auch nicht so viel weiß.
Blackbeard, der mit dem schwarzen Bart.
Genau, genau.
Und was war, was war, man weiß nicht viel, was weiß man denn, dass es die gab?
Dass es einfach die gab und dass die sehr erfolgreich waren.
Hatten die dann auch, also man stellt sich einmal vor, ein Pirat, ein Schiff, also so ein Piraten-Schiff.
Die sind dann durchaus auch in Verbänden gesegelt.
Das heißt, die hatten dann auch schon große Häfen, viele Schiffe.
Häfen wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt, aber es ist dann quasi schon von Hafen zu Hafen gewandert, aber je nachdem, was gerade da war oder was gerade möglich war, auch zu mehreren Verbänden zusammengeschlossen.
Wie meinst du das, von Hafen zu Hafen? Ich dachte, sie haben vor allem immer ihren Hideout gehabt?
Sie haben ihren Hideout gehabt, aber den hat man nicht immer halten können. Tartuga und Jamaika waren natürlich die großen Piratenhäfen, aber auf den anderen kleinen Inseln ist es natürlich immer wieder vorgekommen, dass die Spanier oder die Engländer oder die Holländer einfach mal an Piratenhafen aufgemischt oder geschliffen haben. Und die sind dann durchaus auch im Verband losgezogen, diese großen Piraten.
Und warum war Tartuga eigentlich so?
Tartuga hat einen sehr praktischen, natürlichen Hafen, der sehr gut zu überwachen ist.
Einen?
Genau.
Das heißt, da gab es auch nur eine Piratengemeinde pro Zeitpunkt und der war aber die ganze Zeit umstritten?
Es hat mehrere Piraten gegeben, es war quasi ein Homebase und auch auf Jamaika hat es diese Homebases gegeben, wo die Piraten dann untereinander einen Handel betrieben haben. Und das ist eben das praktische an Tartuga, dass der Hafen so super praktisch war und so sehr gut zu überwachen war.
Das heißt, da wollten eigentlich alle sein, aber nur der Stärkste kam durch und die Piraten haben sich untereinander ihre Häfen streitig gemacht.
Da hat eigentlich jeder hin können, nur kann es natürlich passieren, dass man dann im Hafen umbracht wird oder ausgeraubt wird von anderen Piraten und er hat wie gesagt zu den großen Piraten, wie bereits erwähnt, die letztlich auch dadurch groß geworden sind, weil sie einfach in der Popkultur vorgekommen sind, weil sie ein bisschen verklärt worden sind als mytische Piratenfiguren, vor allem eine Art edle Ritter. Sagen wir mal so, oft auch gern von hoher Herkunft und die Ideale des Adels quasi auf das Schiff übertragen haben.
Das klingt schon so ein bisschen nach Propaganda der etablierten Bürgerfront, die damit selber eigentlich beruhigt werden.
Wahrscheinlich kommt das daher. Wenn ich mich als Kind zurückdenke, haben mir immer die Piraten besser gefallen, die irgendwie ein bisschen grausig waren. Also die dreckig waren, die quasi keine Adelsnamen gehabt haben oder gesagt haben, nein, ich bin ein Adeliger, ich lasse das nicht zu auf meinem Schiff, dass so viel rumgetrunken wird. Oder beten wir zu Gott. Mein Lieblingsfilm-Pirat ist ja Walter Mata aus Piraten von Roman Polanski.
Da wollte ich jetzt sowieso nochmal fragen, aber vielleicht mit den Filmen. Vielleicht nochmal kurz bei den Personen, dass wir nicht zu viel sprechen. Also Henry Morgan, Blackbeard, okay, das sind einfach, du sagst das einfach so, eine Verklärung, das sind einfach Namen, die man kennt, aber ist das jetzt nicht so, dass in der Geschichtsschreibung irgendwie besonders viel darüber wirklich bekannt wäre, was sie nun konkret getrieben haben oder was dazu geführt hat, dass sie jetzt besonders bekannt wurden? Es hätten auch irgendwelche anderen sein können.
Es ist eben bekannt, welche Schiffe sie überfallen haben, welche Häfen, welche Städte und so weiter sie überfallen haben und das sind eben drei Exponate dieser Zeit, die einfach sehr erfolgreich waren. Okay, das heißt, sie werden um Erfolg definiert.
Das heißt, die Strategien, die sie gefahren haben, die Ziele, die sie sozusagen sich eigen gemacht haben.
Und das Geld, das sie eingenommen haben.
Und das Geld, das sie eingenommen haben. Und haben denn dieses, ich meine, wenn man jetzt so viel, wenn man so erfolgreich jetzt als Pirat und so viel Geld einsammelt, was haben die denn damit gemacht? Ich meine, man sitzt doch nicht die ganze Zeit auf einer Insel, auf so einer Schatztruhe mit irgendwie Silberstücken drin und freut sich. Ich meine, Geld hat ja nun im Wirtschaftssystem auch nur dann einen Wert, wenn man sich davon was kaufen kann. Das heißt, die Piraten waren ja im Prinzip entweder angewiesen, sich ihren Luxus, ihren Überlebensluxus, also Nahrungsmittel und was weiß ich, was damals so im Ansatz die Konsumgüterindustrie gewesen sein mag, entweder klauen sie sich das permanent, das ist so von der Hand in den Mund. Aber das ist ja auch mühsam und das ist ja auch gefährlich, also ist ja auch ein gewisses Risiko damit verbunden. Ist es nicht so, dass sie dann hintenrum am normalen Handel auch teilgenommen haben, weil es eigentlich, wenn man Geld hat, ja sehr viel einfacher ist, sich mit Geld die Sachen zu holen, als jetzt jedes Mal jemand abzumuchsen?
Natürlich. Also der Idealweg war ja eigentlich, eine Ware zu stellen, die Ware dann irgendwo zu veräußern und so wie mit dem Geld, so wie wir das ja auch machen, eben das zu kaufen, was man braucht. Das hat durchaus so funktioniert.
Ja gut, aber wenn man jetzt mitten in der Karibik auf so einer Insel rum sitzt, dann gibt es ja überhaupt keine Wirtschaftsinfrastruktur drum herum.
Ja, es gibt auf jeder Insel zumindest einen Hafen oder den meisten Inseln einen Hafen und eine Stadt, wo man einkaufen kann.
Ja gut, das heißt, die Piraten haben sich eigentlich unter normalen, nicht-Piraten-Bürgern auch aufgehalten.
Natürlich, ja.
Die haben jetzt nicht alleine da auf ihrer Insel? Und inwiefern waren sie dann unbehelligt? Also, wenn man sich dann auch auf gleichem Ort andockt, war das dann einfach nicht bekannt, dass sie zu diesen Piraten gehören? Waren die dann so undercover unterwegs oder?
Entweder so oder, wie bereits sehr oft erwähnt, man hat sowieso für den englischen König gesegelt. Dann hat man sie besser von spanischen Häfen ferngehalten. Aber in den englischen Häfen waren wir durchaus unbehelligt.
Das heißt, es gab einfach eine besiedelte Insel, da waren einfach normale Menschen, die irgendwie was weiß ich getan haben, Schiffe gebaut haben, Tische gebaut haben, irgendwie Bananen gebraten haben, Schwerter geschmiedet haben und ein gut Teil davon waren halt einfach die Piraten, die waren halt irgendwie in Lohn und Brot bei dem aktuellen Piraten Schiff.
Ja, oder die sind einfach quasi wirklich nur zum Einkaufen gekommen. Von der anderen Insel, genau, Shopping-Tour, ein Samstagsbummel.
Und die Frauen, die du erwähnt hast, die Piratinnen, das muss ja schon was Besonderes gewesen sein.
Das war durchaus was Besonderes, Anne Bonny und Mary Reed, zwei große Piratinnen, beide aus dem englischen Raum, sind insofern so zu Piratrie gekommen, dass sie sich immer zuerst als Mann verkleidet haben, sind dann auf die Piratenschiffe gekommen. Ich glaube, Anne Bonny war die erste, die sich dann quasi als Frau geoutet hat. Ich hoffe, das stimmt jetzt. Ich hoffe, ich verwechsel die beiden jetzt nicht, jedenfalls. Ja, war sie auf einem Piratenschiff, auf das dann auch die Mary Reed gekommen ist, als Mann verkleidet. Eine total bizarre Geschichte, jedenfalls hat sich die Anne Bonny dann ein bisschen in die Mary Reed verschaut. Da hat sie gesagt, das ist ein hübscher junger Mann, der gefällt mir. Bis sich die Mary Reed dann als Frau geoutet hat und so weiter. Und ich springe kurz zum Ende der beiden. Beiden wurden gefangen genommen, wurden allerdings nicht umgebracht, weil sie beide schwanger waren. Und da hat dann quasi das Gesetz gesagt, anscheinend, eine schwangere Frau wird nicht aufgehängt. Sehr höflich.
Und so konnten sie dann in Gefängnis haften?
Eine davon, Anne Bonny, ist glaube ich im Gefängnis am Fieber gestorben. Und ich glaube von Mary Reed weiß man gar nichts mehr, was quasi ihr Ende war. Aber es gibt natürlich auch um diese zwei Frauen zigtausende Legenden. Also die klassische Duell am Schiff, der Mann schneidet ihr das Hemd auf, sieht, dass es eine Frau ist, man denkt, und sie sticht ihn ab. Schocking.
Oder sie hat es selbst geöffnet.
Erfolgreiches Strategie.
War bestimmt extrem schockierend für so einen normalen Durchschnittspiraten.
Denkt man sich auch nicht, nur die Hausfrau hat auch einen Bart zuhause. Oder die Ehefrau, der Ehe-Mann.
Also man kommt an der Popkultur irgendwie nicht vorbei.
Man kommt an der Popkultur nicht vorbei.
Jetzt hast du schon den Film Piraten von Polanski erwähnt. Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, ob ich den eigentlich schon mal gesehen habe. Walter Matthau, ich kann mich natürlich an die Bilder erinnern, aber ich befürchte fast nicht. Was ist denn an dem Film so besonders?
Erstens Walter Matthau.
Der ist besonders.
Der ist einfach wirklich besonders. Und ich glaube, wenn ich den Film jetzt zum ersten Mal sehen würde, würde ich mir immer denken, Piratenfilm heute. Aber er war für mich als Kind einfach ein wahnsinniger Film. Er hat quasi alles drin gehabt, was ich brauche von einem Piratenfilm. Also viele Kämpfe, eine hübsche Gouverneurs-Tochter, Schätze, ein Art Steakenschatz, ein bisschen dumme Piraten, die ein bisschen dreckig sind und irgendwie nicht wirklich erfolgreich sind, aber lieb, die total viel rumtrinken und alles in einer unglaublich opulenten Inszenierung. Und ein totaler Flop an den Kinokassen, das hat mich als Kind interessanterweise immer total fasziniert. Kino-Flops, aber das ist ein ganz anderes Thema.
Was sind noch so andere wichtige Piratenfilme? Also was mir noch einfällt, ist natürlich Errol Flynn.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich finde Errol Flynn ein bisschen furchtbar. Also ich finde ihn irgendwie ein bisschen...
Er ist mehr so der, das Beauty-Teil, der so...
Genau, genau, genau, genau, genau. Na vielleicht ist er... Vielleicht ist er auch quasi dieser... Vielleicht verkörpert er für mich auch ein bisschen zu sehr diesen edlen Adeligen-Piraten. Die sind ja immer total schön angezogen. Der nicht einmal im schwarz-weiß... Wo man sogar im schwarz-weiß-Film merkt, dass der nicht dreckig ist.
Nicht dreckig, nicht betrocknet, auch.
Nicht dreckig und nicht... Genau, genau, genau.
Nur so edel und hilfreich und...
Genau. Ich verlange von einem gescheiten Filmbiraten, dass der rum beim Bad seitlich runter rennt. Das ist die mindeste Anforderung.
Dreckig muss er sein. Es muss stinken. Den Schweiß bis in die erste Sitzreihe riechen.
So ist es. Und ich oute mich jetzt. Ich sag's jetzt. Ich finde ja Pirates of the Caribbean super. Alle drei Teile.
Aber...
Ich geb's zu.
Na, aber der ist ja auch immer... Na, okay, der ist auch ein bisschen dreckig, oder?
Der ist auch ein bisschen dreckig und sehr schön eigentlich im zweiten und dritten Teil.
Muss man sich da outen? Ist das nicht eigentlich Konsens?
Gute Frage, das stimmt eigentlich. Ich wollte da ein bisschen vorbeugen, vielleicht.
Ja, es ist schon ein Meisterwerk.
Es ist schon ein Meisterwerk. Und man muss sagen, wie es ist. Es ist wirklich von Disney. Ich mein, Disney ist ja eigentlich wirklich ein Wahnsinn. Also die machen wirklich orge Sachen. Aber Pirates of the Caribbean ist wirklich gelungen.
Na, aber Piraten waren die auch immer schon ganz vorne. Manchmal auch so Peter Pan.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt. Weil es ist interessant, es gibt eigentlich alle Varianten von Piraten, es gibt den Piraten, jetzt hatten wir ihn schon, den geschniegelten, adligen, glatten, immer wohlfrisierten, roten Korsan. Dann gibt es den dreckigen, stinkenden, besoffenen, leicht debilen Walter Mattau. Aber dann gibt es auch dieses Urbild des Bösen mit Haken, arm, der immer den Kindern Böses will.
Den man nie trauen kann, auf alle Fälle.
Genau, der immer hinterhältig ist.
Aber Hucki ist ein lächerlicher Pirat, wenn er sich nicht einmal gegen Kinder durchsetzen kann.
Ja gut, da steckt natürlich für die Kinder auch immer dieses Ding drin.
Macht der Fantasie und das Zusammenziehen wir stark mit Liebe und natürlich, natürlich, das darf man jetzt nicht so runter machen.
Dass da auch der Pirat sozusagen, gleichzeitig das Bild sowohl des bösen Debilen als auch des wohlmeinenden Super-Eleganten in einer Rolle irgendwie drin ist.
Stimmt, es lässt sich irgendwie alles auf ihn projizieren. Also er ist quasi Sozialheld und Verbrecher gleichzeitig.
Ja. Was ist da der Grund dafür?
Na ja, quasi das schlechte Image der Piraten ist natürlich insofern erklärbar, dass die Piraterie natürlich immer ein Feind des globalen Wirtschaftsgefüges war oder ein Feind der nationalen Wirtschaftsinteressen war. Und wenn Piraten, wenn die Köpfe von Piraten in Dondern auf einem Speer gesteckt werden, dann hat das natürlich eine gewisse Wirkung. Dann hat das eine gewisse Wirkung, genau. Da denkt man sich dann, der wird schon etwas angestellt haben.
Ja, war in der Zeitung.
War in der Zeitung. Das muss wahr sein. Das muss wahr sein, so ist es. Also ich glaube nämlich eher, dass das sogar noch mehr Wirkung hat als eine Zeitungsschlagzelle.
Als dann das goldene Zeitalter sich dem Ende entgegen neigte. Also was ja gesagt, 1730, jetzt mal so als nicht belegbare, grobe Zeitraum ausgelöst, dadurch, dass sich quasi die Spanier, die Franzosen und die Engländer alle so weit zusammengeschlossen haben und gesagt haben, das nimmt jetzt Überhand hier mit den Piraten, Kappa Brif hin, Kappa Brif her, es schadet uns insgesamt mehr, als dass es uns nützt. Das ist auch eine sehr ökonomische Entscheidung an der Stelle gewesen.
Genau, dann sind sie draufgekommen, wir sollten die Festungen auch hinten große Mauern aufstellen. Das sind so einfache Dinge, aber trotzdem. Und die Gouverneure wurden dazu verpflichtet, gegen die Piraterie zu kämpfen. War früher auch nicht so. Da hat sich ein Gouverneur gedacht, mein Gott, du überfallst meinen Hafen nicht, dafür bringst du mir ein bisschen was von deinen Schätzen, lässt dich ja aushandeln. Die zigtausend Kilometer entfernt von der Hauptstadt. Aber dort, wie sich dieses globale Wirtschaftssystem einfach schneller geworden ist und wie das einfach in sich enger zusammengearbeitet hat, hat man sich dann eben quasi gemeinsam entschieden, dem Feind, nämlich den Piraten, einfach den Chaos machen zu wollen.
Und das haben sie dann auch erfolgreich gemacht.
Das haben sie eigentlich recht erfolgreich gemacht.
Genau. Und einfach durch die Karl-Schlag-Methode, sozusagen.
Einfach durch die Karl-Schlag-Methode.
Einfach alle umbringen und tschüss.
Genau, genau. Also wir behandeln das Problem jetzt nicht an der Wurzel, sondern wir reißen die Wurzel aus.
Ja, es ist interessant, dass das damals noch so funktioniert hat. Heute hat man so den Eindruck, greift das irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig. Gut, dann war das Goldene Zeitalter vorbei. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es keine Piraten mehr gegeben haben wird. Sicherlich gab es dann auch weiterhin noch eine Weide Piraten. Gibt es dann andere Orte, an denen sich das dann... Ist das so wie mit den gefassten Drogendealern? Die gehen dann irgendwie woanders hin und dann war das dann nicht mehr in der Karibik, sondern woanders, wo der Druck nicht so stark war?
Ja, es hat sich allerdings... Quasi sind die Karibik-Piraten dann nicht irgendwo anders hingegangen, sondern viele davon gestorben oder haben sich auch zur Ruhe gesetzt oder sind einige auch in ihre Heimatländer zurückgegangen. Afrika hat das dann noch weitergegeben und so weiter. Und rund um die Philippinen gibt es das ja bis heute. Also Piraterie ist nach wie vor ein starkes Problem für die Schifffahrt. Rund um die Philippinen, Indonesien und jetzt natürlich Somalia, der Große.
Weil da im Prinzip dieselbe Voraussetzung gegeben ist wie damals in der Karibik. Es gab irgendwie keine klare Machtordnung, kein etabliertes Staatssystem, was gesagt hätte, so, aber nicht so. Es gibt ja überhaupt keinerlei Küstensicherung, in dem Sinne keine hoheitlichen Aufgaben mehr. Und die Fremdmächte sind sich irgendwie nicht einig, hat man so den Eindruck, oder?
Genau, was man mit Somalia macht. Gekipfelt ist es für mich quasi im Vorschlag von der Schweiz, dass die Schweiz jetzt auch die Piraterie bekämpft. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob sie schon dort sind, aber ja. Tatsächlich, ja. Die Schweiz hat quasi auch angeboten, gegen die Piraten zu kämpfen.
Was betrifft die Schweiz?
Na ja, das betrifft einfach alle.
Das ist einfach der internationale Hand.
Es ist einfach eine wichtige Straße, eine wichtige Seestraße. Und wie gesagt, es gibt keine Küstenwache. Man hat auch eine Tsunami gesehen im Jahr 2004, war der, glaube ich. Also eine große Tsunami in Thailand, der ja dann Stunden später quasi auch in Afrika angekommen ist, wo in Kenia, glaube ich, eine Person gestorben ist, die einfach zufällig am Strand war und sonst quasi war alles evakuiert und in Somalia viel, viel mehr Menschen gestorben sind. Ich weiß jetzt die genaue Zahl nicht, weil es einfach keine Informationen gegeben hat. Es gibt quasi keine Küstenwache, die sagt, geht es vom Strand. Es gibt kein Radio, das sagt, geht es vom Strand. Das heißt, der totale Anarchismus dort. Und da kann man sich entweder auch entscheiden. Die Fischen ist sehr schwierig dort, weil es keine Küstenwache gibt, das heißt, die internationalen Fischfangflotten schauen jetzt polemisch gesagt einfach mal auf einen Sprung vorbei und werfen das Netz aus und fahren wieder weiter. Und da bleibt für ein kleines Fischerboot nicht viel übrig, das heißt, wovon lebt man.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich die Europäer da auch ganz gut unterwegs, oder?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ja. Wahrscheinlich schon. Und da ist halt die Frage, wird man islamistischer Fundamentalist oder wird man Pirat?
Das ist eigentlich so die große Entscheidung, die in Somalia ansteht.
Das ist jetzt natürlich total aus meiner verklärten westeuropäischen Sicht, wenn ich Ihnen das unterstelle.
Ja gut, aber es ist nachvollziehbar, ich meine, es gibt da keine klare Ordnung. Und ich meine, gibt es irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, dass die Piraten dort ähnlich im Gleichteilermodus sind, wie die Piraten einst?
Interessanterweise den einzigen Artikel, den ich dahingehend gelesen habe, habe ich in der österreichischen Kronen-Zeitung gelesen.
Kein für ausführliche Recherche.
Genau, die den Piraten in Somalia so eine dreiseitige Foto-Reportage gewidmet haben, wo sie gesagt haben, ja, die Piraten holen ihre Beute, teilen das auf in den Gemeinden, geben den Kranken zu essen. Also die gleiche, komplett gleiche romantische Verklärung. Ob es jetzt stimmt oder nicht, kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht nachvollziehen. Ich kann mir allerdings schon vorstellen, dass gewisse Dorfgemeinschaften auch wieder so entstehen, quasi, dass manche Dorfmitglieder zur See fahren, das Geld heimbringen und dort zumindest irgendein Geld heimbringen. Das heißt, irgendwelche Güter überhaupt bringen können oder kaufen können.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das in gewisser Hinsicht für so eine Bewegung auch wichtig ist, um auf dem Festland dann auch den entsprechenden Rückhalt zu haben. Weil machen wir uns nichts vor, die Piraterie, wie sie da betrieben wird, erfordert schon eine gewisse Logistik. Da wird da international ausgedealt, da wird dann im Flugzeug irgendwo das Lösegeld abgeschmissen. Das muss eingesammelt werden. Auch das bedarf einer gewissen Sicherheit, dass man dann als Pirat dann auf dem Land das auch gleich wieder wegpiratiert bekommt. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das nicht ohne eine umfangreiche Unterstützung, zumindest von einem bestimmten Teil der real existierenden Gesellschaft mitgetragen werden muss. Wie kann man das besser machen, als wenn man eben sagt, ihr seid ein Teil davon. Ihr profitiert davon, dass ihr diese Aktivität jetzt unterstützt. Das ist jetzt auch von mir nur so mal weiter philosophiert. Wir würden jetzt noch ein paar andere, wahrscheinlich absolut schwer zu belegende Vergleiche machen. Was mir einfällt, ist, wie die Hamas zum Beispiel im Gaza-Streifen auch die Unterstützung des Volkes hat. Von den eigentlichen Zielen und Vorgehensweisen der Hamas mal ganz abgesehen. Aber es ist ja offensichtlich, dass sie eben die Unterstützung in der Gesellschaft deshalb haben, weil sie nach hinten eben genau dieses Prinzip auch haben. Wir geben Kredite aus, wir helfen euch, wir verteilen Essen und so weiter. Welche Ziele sie damit eigentlich beabsichtigen, sei mal ganz dahingestellt. Aber es wäre ja durchaus vorstellbar, dass auch dieses Piratentum in Somalia sich ähnlich absichert.
Genau.
Weil man eigentlich auch diese Gleichteilung wieder macht.
Also besser Geld von einem Piraten als gar kein Geld.
Ja, weil es gibt ja irgendwie nichts. Auch die islamistischen Gruppen haben ja zum Beispiel, bis sie dann wiederum von den Amerikanern und Äthiopiern dann auch wieder vertrieben wurden, in Somalia durchaus auch Inseln der Ruhe geschaffen, indem sie da wieder eine gewisse Grundordnung in die Bezirke gebracht haben.
Ja, aber das hält eben nicht lang. Ich glaube, es braucht auch nicht die Äthiopie oder die Amerikaner dazu, dass es wieder mal kracht.
Das kann gut sein. Also ich meine, wer von uns blickt jetzt schon Somalia durch? Wir stochern jetzt hier auch so ein bisschen.
Somalia ist irgendwie medial wieder präsent und eigentlich nur durch die Piraterie.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch nicht nur Somalia. Also es ist ja genauso gut auch im Jemen, soweit ich weiß. Ein Problem, du hast die Philippinen schon genannt.
Genau, Indonesien.
Indonesien, das sind alles diese dichten Schifffahrtsstraßen. Also man sieht eigentlich, dass dieses Piratentum, obwohl es irgendwie schon immer in dieser Spätantike des 16., 17. Jahrhunderts verankert ist, dass es eigentlich immer noch ein voll aktuelles Thema ist. Die Frage ist, wann geht es weg?
Nie. Also ich glaube, es geht nie weg.
Solange es Schiffe gibt, gibt es Piraterie.
Solange es Schiffe gibt und dann wird es Raumschiffe geben und Piratenraumschiffe.
Aber die Luftpiraterie, die hat nicht so Konjunktur.
Die ist technisch auch sehr schwer umsetzbar. Weil, wie wir eben bereits gesagt haben, wichtig war für einen Piraten, dass das Schiff nicht versenkt wird. Das ist beim Luftangriff schwierig. Also in ein Flugzeug reinzukommen, ohne dass das kaputt wird.
Und wo soll man auch schon landen? Man braucht halt immer diese großen Häfen.
Genau, also die großen Landebahnen auf den Pirateninseln sind glaube ich noch immer nicht.
Ja, ist auch schon lange nichts mehr entführt worden. Kann ich mich nicht so richtig daran erinnern.
Wobei Flugzeugentführungen ja glaube ich selten um die Ware gehen, sondern oft politischen Backgrounds.
Ja, und Flucht und so weiter.
Vielleicht Lösegeld.
Also früher mag das mal noch eine nennenswerte Beute gewesen sein, aber ein Flugzeug heutzutage zu verstecken ist glaube ich ziemlich sinnlos. Tja, was nimmt man so mit aus dieser Piratengeschichte? Also was hast du dich aus der Kindheit heraus damit beschäftigt? Beschäftigt sich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch immer noch damit, wenn wieder neues Material kommt. Bist du da auch ein bisschen selber am Forschen oder ist das eigentlich nur die Abfallprodukte?
Nein, das ist ein reines Hobby.
Und was kann man daraus lernen? Also gibt es da, was sind so die interessanten Botschaften, die aus diesem Piratenwesen hervorsteigen?
Für mich die interessanteste Botschaft ist eigentlich, dass die romantische Verklärung gar nicht so verklärt ist. Sagen wir mal so. Also dass es dieses Gleichheitsding sehr wohl auch gegeben hat und sehr interessante, nennen wir sie mal, basisdemokratische Projekte. Dann, was man daraus auch mitnehmen kann, ist quasi eine Art Geschichte des internationalen Proletariats, das sich da quasi auf diesen Schiffen zum ersten Mal gebildet hat. Das heißt, es waren arme Menschen aus allen Nationen, die einerseits…
Das erste Mal gebildet hat im Sinne von noch vor auf dem Land, oder wie?
Genau.
Prä-industrielles Proletariat.
Genau. Also nicht quasi die Fabrik als Geburtsstunde des Kapitalismus, sondern bereits das Schiff als Geburtsstunde des Kapitalismus, wo quasi jeder eine fixe Aufgabe zu erledigen hat. Also da meine ich jetzt gar nicht nur Piraten, sondern die Schifffahrt allgemein so dieser Zeit.
Genau. Und was ja auch sozusagen eine Maschine ist.
Genau, was eine Maschine ist. Eine Maschine, die fahren muss.
Also eigentlich sind die Schiffe die ersten wirklichen Wirtschaftsmaschinen gewesen.
Genau, genau. Wie gesagt, jeder hat eine bestimmte Aufgabe, die muss er zu 100 Prozent erfüllen. Wenn er die nicht erfüllt, hat der nächste ein Problem und so weiter und so weiter. Das kann man da auf alle Fälle mitnehmen und das da quasi eine, nennen wir sie mal wirklich, internationale Gemeinschaft entstanden ist auf diesen Schiffen, die auch eine Art eigene Sprache entwickelt hat, weil natürlich jeder eine andere Sprache gesprochen hat, hat man sich irgendwo in der Mitte treffen müssen.
Gab es so eine Art Piraten-Esperanto?
Überhaupt Schifffahrts-Esperanto, nennen wir es einmal so. Also Esperanto, so quasi, aber gar nicht so weit weg von Esperanto, nur eher auf Englisch oder auf Spanisch, das ist glaube ich, Esperanto hauptsächlich passierend, oder?
Naja, so auf dem lateinischen.
Genau, genau, genau.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht so sehr auf Esperanto.
Ja, aber die Seefahrersprache, genau, so eine gemeinsame Sprache, die man einfach in den Häfen und so weiter auch gesprochen hat und ein kiezerkleiner Exkurs, den ich da noch gerne machen würde. Es gibt da in der Forschung diesen einen Punkt, das jetzt quasi diese internationale Gemeinschaft nicht nur auf den Schiffen gegeben hat, sondern auch auf den Plantagen in Nord- und Südamerika, wo natürlich immer ein riesiges Konfliktpotenzial, dass die Machthaber, die Plantagenbesitzer natürlich immer Angst gehabt haben, dass sich dieses Potenzial der versklavten Iren, versklavten Engländer, versklavten Afrikaner da mal gemeinsam entfalten könnte. Und sind dann irgendwann draufgekommen, naja, wir können dem doch mit Rassenlehre entgegenwirken, indem wir zu den Iren und Engländern sagen, ihr seid zwar auch Leib-Eigene, aber ihr seid so ein bisschen besser als die Afrikaner. Und das hat dann auf den Schiffen eben genauso funktioniert. Also man hat quasi die Rassenlehre, wenn nicht gar erfunden, aber zumindest benützt, um quasi Zwidracht in dieser Basis zu sehen.
Verstehe. Ihr seid alle gar nicht gleich, sondern die einen sind dann doch ein bisschen gleicher als die anderen.
Genau, besser gesagt, ihr seid alle schlecht, aber der ist ein bisschen schlechter.
Und die Weißen waren natürlich dann bei default besser als die Schwarzen.
Genau, das ist durchaus ein interessanter Punkt, auf den ich erst gekommen bin, wie ich mich mit diesen Dingen beschäftigt habe.
Generell, wenn man so eine Herrscher von Leuten hat, die für einen arbeiten, obwohl sie eigentlich die Mehrheit sind und kräftig genug im Prinzip, sich gar nicht aufstehen gegen diese Unterdrückung, dann muss man Psychotricks heranziehen.
Genau, also es hat genug Versuche und Aufstände, Haiti 1800, wo die Sklaven alle Plantagenbesitzer vertrieben haben, die dann auf Kuba gelandet sind. Was rückwirkend allerdings auch wieder dazu geführt hat, dass die viele Weiße auf nordafrikanischen Plantagen gesagt haben, das wollen wir dann doch nicht. Also selbst quasi Plantagen-Sklafe, aber dann haben sie gesagt, nein, das wollen wir auch nicht. Das ist quasi ein bisschen nach hinten losgegangen.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Was ist nach hinten losgegangen? Auf Haiti haben sie die Plantagenbesitzer vertrieben?
Vertrieben, genau. Und dann haben quasi viele Weiße Leib-Eigene in Nord- und Südamerika gesagt, so wollen wir das eigentlich gar nicht, also solche Aufstände wollen wir nicht. Und gesagt haben, ja dann bleiben wir doch lieber ein bisschen auf Seiten unserer Plantagenbesitzer und lassen uns von denen ein bisschen bevorzugt.
Wollen sie das nicht, weil es dann in Haiti nicht geklappt hat, weil ihnen die logistischen Bauabfäden…
In Haiti hat es zwar geklappt, aber es war ein ziemliches Massaker.
Ich meine, man hat ja so eine ähnliche Bewegung jetzt in Simbabwe gehabt, wo dann auch die Plantagenbesitzer vertrieben wurden, wenn auch aus anderen Gründen. Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass ihnen einfach das ganze Know-how verloren gegangen ist und die die Plantagen weiter betreiben konnten, so wie die Farmen an der Stelle.
Genau, und dass es quasi viele Bewegungen gegeben hat, von denen man einfach wenig weiß. Also es hat viele Aufstände gegeben, es hat 1741, glaube ich, und Versuche gegeben, New York zu übernehmen, zusammen von Piraten, Hafenarbeitern, Sklaven und so weiter. Es war sehr knapp sogar, sie haben nur ein bisschen zu früh das Fort George, die damalige Festung in der Stadt, niedergebrannt. Also es hat wirklich Versuche gegeben, diese Bewegung quasi gemeinsam gegen den großen Feind, also die herrschende Klasse, loszuschlagen. Es hat einfach nie wirklich funktioniert, außer eben auf kleinen Inseln, wo zum Beispiel in Jamaika sogenannte Maroons, das sind quasi freies Sklaven, die sich die Freiheit erkämpft haben, einfach gelebt haben in freien Siedlungen. Es hat immer wieder so kleine Nester und so weiter gegeben, wo es Freiheit gegeben hat, eben auch in diesen Piratenhäfen. Freiheit hat ja eigentlich wenig Weiß, weil man immer nur von den großen Seefahrern, großen Eroberern und Schlachten gewinnen hört. Aber es hat quasi nie diese wirklich gemeinsame Bewegung gegeben.
Also die Piraten konnten sich nicht einigen, wollten sie ja auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Ich denke nicht.
Und vielleicht nochmal so dieses, meintest du ja, es gibt diese träumerische Verklärung, aber sie ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch angemessen. Im Prinzip ist es ja auch so ein wenig Utopia. Dieser Urtraum, der Insel, wo alle sich gleich stellen und vor allem auch gegenseitig unterstützen, dass da schon eine Art Grundeinkommen gibt und so weiter. So mag es da jetzt nicht im Einzelnen funktioniert haben, aber auch da sind natürlich auch utopische Elemente im Prinzip mit drin.
Ich schätze, dass diese Vorstellungen nicht ungefähr meistens in der Karibik angesiedelt sind. Diese Utopier-Vorstellung. Also wenn man sich das vorstellt, habe ich für mich persönlich immer Palmen im Kopf und Kokosnüsse. So wie es auf Tattoo-Geist gewesen ist.
Ja, aber es ist ganz schön heiß da. Da schwitzt man bestimmt auch die Seele aus dem Leib. Ich habe das mal gemacht in der Karibik. Ich fand das gar nicht so toll.
Wieso?
Da wegen der Karibe. Die Karibe, das sind diese kleinen Klebstoffe, die da irgendwie immer ins Wasser gespült werden. Man kommt irgendwie aus dem Wasser raus und klebt alles so ein bisschen.
Das kommt davon, wo man ist, oder?
Ja, das war in Kuba. Ah, wo denn? Das war Nordkuba.
Okay, da war ich auch schwimmen, aber das war hübsch.
Das ist so die Ecke, wo Kolumbus gelandet ist. Da war ich.
Ich war auf einer Landesstelle im Süden.
Mich hat es gleich an den historischen Ort gelesen.
Ich glaube, es gibt fünf oder so auf Kuba.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall genug Strand. Das ist eigentlich ein schönes Land, ein bisschen anstrengend, aber ein schönes Land. Noch mal vielleicht zum Schluss auf die Pop-Kultur. Außer den Filmen. Was hat es denn sonst noch so? Ich meine, bei Hollywood ist es irgendwie ganz stark. Und jetzt auch mit Pirates of the Caribbean eben noch mal dieses Mega-Revival, was meiner Meinung nach, dadurch, dass diese Filme auch so gelungen sind, eine gelungene Trilogie ist ja auch selten, wird es wahrscheinlich noch sehr lange halten. Wahrscheinlich wird es auch nie weggehen, weil einfach dieses, jedes Kind will ein Pirat sein, jedes Kind will irgendwie dieses, ich bin nicht Opfer einer Rechtsordnung, sondern ich bin einfach frei und ich kämpfe irgendwie für meine eigenen Rechte und vor allem auch für meine eigenen Utopien. Das steckt da ja im Prinzip mit drin. Es wird sich einfach halten. Was gibt es denn sonst noch für interessante kulturelle Ausprägungen dieses Piratenphänomens? Gibt es, außer den Filmen und den Büchern vielleicht, Einflussnahmen auf kulturelle Bewegungen, wo du sagen kannst, das ist ein Prinzip auch so, dieses Piratenbild?
Man könnte es natürlich so sagen, dass quasi alles, was irgendwie mit diesem Freiheitsgedanken zusammenspielt und mit diesem Gemeinsam gegen irgendwelche Obrigkeiten aufstehen, abseits politischer Ideologien jetzt so einen gewissen Piraten-Touch hat. So weit ist auch ich das einmal sagen. Allerdings glaube ich auch, dass, wie bereits gesagt, Hollywood und die ganzen Romane und dieser ganze Wahnsinn, dass das einfach so viel ist, dass das letztlich die kulturelle Darstellung des Ganzen ist. Ich wage das jetzt einmal zu behaupten.
Es ist einfach so präsent.
Es ist einfach so präsent. Also ich kann mir keine subkulturelle Piratenreferenz mehr so ein bisschen schwer vorstellen irgendwie. Weil es jetzt nichts gibt, was natürlich in Hollywood gezeigt worden ist oder in irgendwelchen Büchern geschrieben wurde.
Wie ist denn das so mit diesen klassischen Bildern, die man so hat, ich meine, der Papagei, wo kommt das her, gab es?
Das weiß ich, ich muss gestehen, ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Es gibt schon Papageien in Südamerika, aber...
Ja, aber ich meine, es gab vielleicht einen Piraten, der jetzt tatsächlich so einen auf der Schulter hatte oder am Arm oder in seinem Käfig, wo das irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt hat, mit dem er sich beraten hat oder so.
Darüber habe ich, muss ich gestehen, noch nie Gedanken gemacht. Aber ich werde mich, glaube ich, mal mit Google damit auseinandersetzen.
Und die Augenklappe?
Ja, die hat natürlich schon, natürlich, natürlich, gewisse Körperteile hat man einfach verloren im Kampf. Und wie bereits gesagt, man hat je nach Körperteil eine gewisse Entschädigung dafür bekommen. Finger war das wenigste, zwei Hände war das meiste.
Gibt es da tatsächlich überlieferte Tabellen, wie viel das so war?
Genau, genau, genau.
Und das hat dann die Gemeinschaft bezahlt sozusagen. Also im Prinzip war auch so eine kranken, invaliden Versicherung auch ein Teil des Systems.
Genau, ein gewisser Fonds, der recht gut bestückt war mit Geld, aus dem dann diese Sachen bezahlt worden sind.
Toll.
Da gibt man natürlich gern zehn Prozent von seiner Beute ab, wenn man weiß, man verliert einmal eine Hand und kriegt dann Geld dafür.
Da hat die industrielle Revolution lange für gebraucht, bis sie irgendwie solche Sachen...
Ewig. Ja, ewig. Und es ist noch immer mühsam.
Andererseits hat man wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schnell eine Hand verloren und so war es nicht so...
Also, ich glaube, dass man in einer Fabrik des 19. Jahrhunderts wahrscheinlich gleich schnell eine Hand verloren hat, wäre von einem Piraten-Schiff.
Aber es war schon ein bisschen was anderes, wenn man irgendwie so mit Säbel und Messer zwischen den Zehnen auf irgendein Schiff springt.
Aber so eine Dampfmaschine im Prototyp ist, glaube ich, auch nicht zu verachten.
Aber wahrscheinlich war einfach die Gefahr da einfach offensichtlicher, dass man gesagt hat, ich springe da jetzt nicht drauf, wenn ich nicht irgendwie eine Krankenversicherung unterscheiden bekomme. Tja, Roland, haben wir noch irgendwas? Was ich vergessen habe, eingangs zu erwähnen, ist bisher auch ein Teil von Monochrom.
Genau.
Hier der Künstlervereinigung. Ihr seid ja auch so ein bisschen hier so die Kunstpiraten, oder?
Kann man sagen, ja. Aber wir beuten niemanden aus. Also wir überfallen niemanden.
Ihr seid schon etabliert.
Wir sind die Henry Morgens.
Ich habe ja mit Johannes hier auch schon mal gesprochen. Ich weiß gerade die Ausgabe nicht. Kurz mal gucken. Ich glaube, es war die Ausgabe 66. Gucken, ob man das Internet Recht gibt. Wo über die... Nee, stimmt gar nicht. Oh man. Ich kenne meine eigenen Sendungen hier nicht mehr.
Aber ich kenne so viele.
62 war es. Wo wir schon viel über Monochrome geredet haben, das will ich jetzt auch gar nicht irgendwie verändern. Du und Johannes seid ja auch mal sehr sichtbar bei euren Veranstaltungen. Ihr beide seid dann auch nicht nur alleine Monochrome. Es ist noch eine sehr viel größere Gemeinde. Du bist auch recht sichtbar, weil du häufig dabei bist, vor allem bei Talkshow und ähnlichen Sachen. Ist das Piratending aus deiner Jugend, was du sozusagen mitgenommen hast? Ist das für deine künstlerische Identität das Äquivalent? Ist Künstlersein quasi die zivile Piratenform in der Gesellschaft, in unserer gesättigten Gesellschaft?
Wahrscheinlich. Das ist natürlich eine sehr bürgerliche Variante. Ich mache quasi Kunst, aber enthebe mich damit natürlich auch gewissen Regeln.
Du musst nicht auf alles achten, du hast so eine gewisse Narrenfreiheit.
Ich habe eine gewisse Narrenfreiheit, stimmt eigentlich, man kann sich verkleiden. Auch gerne als Pirat, ohne dass man blöd angeschaut wird. Das ist sehr angenehm überhaupt.
Wolltest du nicht schon mal einen Piratenfilm drehen? Schauspielern, stell euch doch mal auf die Bühne und macht doch mal was Piratiges.
Als letztes, was wir gespielt haben, das ist eh schon lange her, das war eine Performance der Piratenpartei, wo Johannes und ich zwei britische Offiziere gespielt haben, die den damaligen Chef der österreichischen Piratenpartei verhaftet haben.
Warum denn das?
Versteh man so als Performance?
Die Anti-Piraterie. Da hast du ja die Seiten gewechselt.
Ja, nur für die Performance. Obwohl mein Herz geblutet hat. Aber wir wurden dann am Ende von der Piraten-Meute überzeugt und haben uns die richtigen Hüte aufgesetzt und ein lautstarkes Yo-Ho ausgeschrien und dann hat's wieder gepasst.
Und dann gab's eine Budele voll rum.
Dann gab's eine Budele voll Daten und dann rum, ja.
Gut, dann machen wir Schluss, wa? Wenn wir noch was ganz Wichtiges vergessen haben, haben wir nicht oder haben wir wahrscheinlich. Das war der Ausriss in die Piratenwelt, fand ich super interessant, hab auch ein paar Sachen davon noch nicht gesehen. Und jetzt wissen wir alle, dass von Piraterieträumen durchaus was Handfestes hat und auch mit ja, freiheitlichen Idealen noch mehr zu tun hat, als manchmal von der Gegenseite immer unterstellt wird. Wir haben die Piraten jetzt verteidigt und vielen Dank. Mir auch und ich grüße alle Hörer und ich hoffe, ihr habt viele piratige Kommentare am Start zu dieser Sendung. Vielleicht wisst ihr ja auch, wo der Mythos mit dem Papagei herkommt.
Bitte, bitte klärt mich auf.
Oder andere Sachen.
Und überhaupt, wenn ich Blödsinn erzählt habe, über was durchaus vorkommen kann, macht es mich nieder.
Genau. Also Roland ist nach wie vor in der Piratenforschung aktiv, ihr könnt dazu beitragen und wenn genug neue Informationen zusammenkommen, dann dreht er auch mal einen Film. Okay, das war's, bis bald und wir hören uns wieder bei Chaosradio Express.